pour n'oubliez pas les
après 700 jours de détention les
premiers instants de liberté retrouvés
en France d'Olivier Dubois grand sourire
et le pas décidé
car ce midi il y a enfin les embrassades
avec les siens
sa sœur qui s'est tentatue pour le
retrouver
puis son père quelques blagues échangées
la libération d'Olivier Dubois fait
réagir ses confrères notamment Julien
qui est journaliste Olivier était le
dernier journaliste retenu en otage à
l'étranger je dis à l'étranger parce
qu'en France les journalistes de cnews
et Europe 1 sont toujours pris en otage
par Vincent Bolloré je travaille
moi-même à cnews on n'a pas un SOS sur
le toit du bâtiment mais personne vient
nous chercher on doit aller à la messe
tous les jours avant le journal de 8h
c'est horrible Gérard Leclerc qui
revient de quelques jours de vacances
vous étiez au ski oui
[Rires]
au Canada oui oui vous êtes revenu
défendez les couleurs françaises parce
que c'est une compétition
alors que le ski c'est parfois dangereux
donc vous êtes un bon skieur ben merci
oui il vous reste à retrouver le chemin
de votre coiffeur avec Emmanuel Macron
la poignée de main est plus protocolaire
mais chaleureuse également
[Musique]
du jour
Mbappe l'attaquant devient le nouveau
capitaine de l'équipe de France
l'annonce en a été faite après un
entretien hier soir entre le
sélectionneur Didier Deschamps et le
principal intéressé il remplace Hugo
Lloris qui a pris sa retraite
internationale et il sera secondé par
Antoine Griezmann désigné vice capitaine
à la place de Raphaël Varane lui aussi
retraitée des Bleus qui a provoqué cette
image
d'émeute devant un restaurant plusieurs
centaines de personnes rassemblées
devant cette entrée qui chante
d'ailleurs
si vous avez si je vous dis c'est en
Argentine
c'est Léo Messi
escortée de ce restaurant mais avec un
large sourire parce que le joueur du PSG
a pu reprendre un petit shot d'amour et
se rendre compte qu'il y a toujours
autant de succès je vais vous présenter
une jeune débutante en politique elle
s'appelle Juliette decosan militante
égalité Europe écologiste c'est un parti
qui soutient Emmanuel Macron c'est tout
ce qu'il faut retenir se présente à une
élection législative partielle pour
pouvoir le poste des députés des
Français de l'étranger dont le premier
tour aura lieu en avril et là j'avoue
que je rigole d'avance parce que c'est
vrai qu'elle est très jolie donc ça
donne vraiment envie de voter pour elle
elle est charmante
de quinquagénaire pour les uns deux
chefs d'entreprise pour les autres
Kilian Mbappé est devenu le propriétaire
de Clairefontaine tout est avec humour
un conte de supporters du PSG un truc du
moins la tenue tout en sobriété du
nouveau capitaine des Bleus a même
surpris son coach je te reconnaissais
pas
inaperçu Didier Deschamps avait en
revanche
dans les Ardennes j'ai retrouvé la fiche
et il y a il y a un petit Pays-Bas
ça me fait penser à un petit peu
avant maquillage et après
elle est habillé pareil donc ça c'est
intéressant de le remarquer en revanche
soit elle a été voir un super docteur
soit il y a en fait
c'est pas une bonne la candidate avoue
qu'elle a juste demandé au graphiste de
je cite
elle a juste demandé au graphiste de
mettre des lumières chaudes comme en
Italie parce que se présente en Italie
ce qu'il a fait manifestement pas de
doutes en revanche ici cette recette
n'est pas la bonne pour réaliser des
pâtes fraîches cette tic-tocqueuse passe
des spaghettis au mixeurs
bref elle est à deux doigts d'inventer
la farine de blé s'amuse à faire
remarquer une internaute mélanger de la
farine du sel et des œufs serait plus
simple plus économique et le résultat
serait probablement moins épais
quelle drôle d'idée voici la fiche donc
de Samira herbal de cette il y a un an
et voici celle de cette année alors oui
on s'aperçoit que la majorité
présidentielle n'était pas contente des
affiches de l'an dernier donc ils les
ont refaites et si vous Vladimir Poutine
avait envoyé un sosie à Mario Paul cette
théorie récurrente revient sur les
réseaux sociaux depuis la diffusion
dimanche par le Kremlin de ces images
hautement symboliques la première visite
du président russe en Ukraine depuis
l'invasion du pays dans un tweet un
conseiller du ministre de l'Intérieur
ukrainien s'attarde sur le menton pour
d'autres les oreilles ne collent pas
avant de se rendre à Mario Paul of
Vladimir Poutine était en Crimée et là
encore une séquence interpelle certains
imaginent une doublure avec un masque
pour Tatiana beauté va Malo et non pas
refait la photo veste blanche écharpe
noire voici donc ça c'est celle de l'an
dernier voici donc la fiche de cette
année même veste blanche
même même écharpe noire mais les cheveux
un peu plus poussé
alors là
alors là je dis non
ouais
une appli est en train de cartonner
cette appli s'appelle snack snack la
promesse via une intelligence
artificielle snack l'appli va draguer à
votre place ce qui est génial snack
bah alors là c'est quand même
snack est décrit comme l'enfant de Tik
Tok et de tinder ce qui vraiment donne
de l'espoir quant à notre avenir à tous
je me suis trompé
moche moi je t'ai trouvé j'ai trop caca
avec tes cheveux en clair vous
remplissez un max de données sur
vous-même l'intelligence artificielle va
vous trouver ce ou celle qui
correspondent le mieux à votre profil et
va entamer la discussion pour vous ce
qui est quand même bien quand on sait
que les débuts de discussion peuvent
être parfois un petit peu compliqué sur
les réseaux sociaux l'appli va même plus
loin puisqu'il travaille la possibilité
de faire en sorte que les utilisateurs
se rencontrent une première fois dans la
métaverse et pas en vrai on va voir le
l'avatar de l'autre et puis si ça match
après on se voit en vrai enfin bref
c'est fantastique je vous rassure non
c'est plutôt de l'ironie il y a une
personne que dont j'ai oublié le nom et
vous comprendrez pourquoi aisément j'ai
oublié son nom qui m'a écrit j'allais
dire gentiment mais je ne crois pas que
ce soit gentiment en disant il y en a
marre de ces candidats qui apprennent
révisent les paroles pour venir dans
l'émission alors
regardez bien le titre de l'émission
monsieur et le principe étant en effet
d'apprendre les paroles et de venir et
de prouver qu'on a une bonne mémoire
c'est le principe de l'émission je peux
comprendre que ça ne vous plaise pas
mais c'est le concept comme on dit et
peut-être que dans ces deux syllabes il
y en a une qui vous parle